last week League of Legends fans got up
in arms over a pretty interesting issue
number act versus night blue riot versus
their players Teemo versus good and when
all was said and done they were left
with two interesting questions one do
streamers have too much influence over
riot and two is picking an off meta
strat a good reason to get ban we're
gonna walk you through what happened
both sides of the argument and by the
hello League streamer compared himself
to Rosa Parks okay let's start at the
beginning
last week League streamer night blue
gone the game with another smaller
streamer called nub Iraq now when he got
into the game night blue was quickly
told to dodge but he decided not to
because he noted that number Ike had a
pretty good win rate way he's winning
bro wait why you why you tell me to
dodge what's wrong with him
the got in-game and number act was
playing support Teemo in the middle and
now for those of you that don't play
League of Legends this is pretty
unorthodox Teemo isn't usually support
in the first place and support players
usually stay in the bot lane and help
their ad carry not leave them high and
dry to go claim it very quickly night
blue reacted negatively what is my Teemo
doing hey Teemo you want to week
vacation bish I'll call my riot friend
right now [ __ ] a friend [ __ ]
okay so night blue was kind of being a
jerk but to be fair to him he didn't
really know what Nebraska's doing and
what number AK was doing at least
according to him was playing a solid off
meta pick why would I go bottom when I
can't do anything maybe I can get spell
thief rocks I couldn't ICS I become
useful when I become useful we win more
games it's it's that simple Silver's
finding a 1v2 like she's only down like
70s see if it's down 10 seus I get to
feed irelia who the [ __ ] doesn't want to
fit our earlier if we take him at his
word he wasn't trolling he was
innovative and to be fair number act
wasn't FINA but my blue wasn't having it
and so he reported na brat
what he didn't do it you and I do when
there's something dumb in one of our
instead he allegedly went to the witch
League of Legends partnership discord
and asked his effort when of Rights
streamer managers to ban na Brock number
after got his 14-day ban and riot only
cited that one game he played with night
Boyle we can't say anything for sure but
it seems relatively cut and dry like
four zero four four zero and two and
night blue 0 into two so then they're
like all right here's the games I was
penalized for right so I go to the
[ __ ] game and here it is
it's [ __ ] the game night blue [ __ ]
AF Kade with my ADC so here's the big
issue here did Knight blue abused his
power he's clearly a big streamer and
obviously riot listens to him at least
enough to look into an issue when he
complains about it personally night blue
and number act actually got on discord
and discussed what happened they've
actually streamed it all if you want to
watch and this week ride actually
responded to Nebraska's support ticket
they said that they feel like Knight
whose behavior was unacceptable in this
circumstance and that they're going to
investigate the issue again they also
told him that he'll be getting a more
formal response soon but we'll keep you
posted on that when it happened this
also isn't the first time this happened
about two months ago a streamer named
Master fiend who was playing support
veigar with tyler one was banned
allegedly after tyler one complain about
masturbating
there is record of riot going in a
little harder than you expect them to
when one of their bigger streamers is
involved but on the other hand it's not
like no brac is a saint there are plenty
of people out there who have played with
nub RAC in the past and did not enjoy
the experience and pro players like
doublelift and jensen have chimed in to
they've said that they would also report
a player if they pick Teemo support and
then went mid and perhaps most insanely
number AK compared himself to Rosa Parks
and MLK who should be legitimately
[ __ ] crazy if he wasn't clearly
trolling did Martin Luther King or Rosa
Parks did they stay silent but
doublelift and Jensen's backlash and yes
even the Brack strolling does raise an
interesting question why would you ever
try to experiment and try new things in
the league it's just gonna get you
banned two years ago I've actually wrote
about this I interviewed a person who
played support nunu but then went to the
enemy jungle and counter jump he
received a two week man and riots
official
is that while his win rate was about 50%
his report rate was about 50% - they
also said that they promote
experimentation in a league and as far
as I can tell they still commit to that
stance they even made a commercial about
it
maybe we'll
but that and is often at odds with the
truth let's assume for a second that
Nebraska's in trolling that he
legitimately thought mid support Teemo
was a viable off meta pick Bryan should
support that the problem is that the
solo queue system itself prevents that
from happening
Wright has spent years designing their
game both from a balance and interface
perspective to encourage a very specific
style of play one top laner one mid
laner bot Lane duo and jungler if you
walk in anything that deviates from that
people will lose their [ __ ] and that
makes sense because it's literally not
how riot has told them the game works
personally I think experimentation is
cool as long as you aren't being
malicious and ruining the game for
anybody else see that Sivir and every
other ad carry he's ever left stranded
in the bot lane was not having any fun
they were just screwed if nub RAC was
playing as a duo with a set partner who
was ready and willing to 1v2 every
single game that'll be another story but
as it stands it's kind of hard to
justify nob rack strat and that's before
we get into past behavior but that
doesn't mean what riot did in this case
was right either
letting a streamer effectively wield the
ban hammer because they had one bad game
is pretty irresponsible and it kind of
sets a bad example for anybody looking
to experiment or anybody who's just
having a rough day look I can't really
tell you who's right we've seen night
blue and nob rack you should make up
your own mind on that but I do think
that riot should do more to encourage
experimentation which is why I'm going
to the frontline get ready for on hit ad
carry Gallio coming soon thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you will find anywhere else hit
up our Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages
[Music]